[Music]
so I do work out at mainstream gyms but
I don't always feel like I fit in
mainstream gyms are very like machismo
and aggressive do go to the gym I you
know I have to go into men's locker room
and you know has somebody that has you
know a past as a woman going into an
all-male space where my you know my body
is very distinctly different is
terrifying the gay community puts a lot
of pressure on men to look a certain way
and because I don't look that way it
makes me feel like something's wrong
with my body this week of working out at
a queer gym is going to be really fun
I'm Samer husky and I'm the founder of
everybody I'm Lake sharp and I am
co-founder everybody is a radically
inclusive holistic gym it's a place to
build community
we welcome you through our doors as you
are you're not required to change
anything we welcome your body as it is
primarily wanted to film the gym because
I wanted a space that I felt comfortable
Hyper body is incredible and is exactly
what someone from the future would look
like this class does not feel like a
mainstream gym class because it takes so
much from queer culture bright colors
high energy a slight shamelessness to
moving that you don't see in mainstream
games I definitely felt like a huge
sense of belonging I did get emotional
at one point in the class definitely
answering to Whitney Houston looking
around at everybody and just seeing
everyone just smile I typically don't
like moving my body in a sexual manner
but this class made it okay and I felt
comfortable to do it and I felt safe to
do it my preferred gender pronoun and
she/her/hers
this is Pony sweat we're gonna move our
bodies for a whole hour I've always
thought I was a good dancer until I took
Ponies wets class there were several
times that I was off beat missing the
steps I was like what is happening here
cuz I can dig it I felt really good when
she started playing Robyn's dancing on
my own I'm already not a very good
dancer so just trying to keep up out of
this like uh say thank you body
[Applause]
I thought the class is a really cool way
to have a little bit of a physical
interaction as well as feeling a
spiritual connection to yourself today
what we're going to do is a nice
restorative yoga class and we're gonna
combine all the postures with a little
bit of breath work and mantra the class
was super relaxing and it felt like a
really good intro into yoga in a way of
just understanding and feeling my body
more put out a blessing to yourself send
out a prayer to your friends your family
whoever needs your support but again
most of all to yourself because if you
are happy that's the only way you're
gonna make other people happy
I knew the classes were gonna be
different I didn't expect them to be so
fun I loved working out at everybody it
was really cool to just kind of be
myself I saw a lot of women
weightlifting which was cool I was like
yes my people the minute I stepped into
everybody I saw people who looked like
me and I was immediately put at ease
having clear gyms across the country
would open so many more people up to
fitness and that'd be great if I could
send a wish to myself it would be to
care for myself and be patient with my
body and it's gonna do its own thing I
just have to work with it and you know
love it the way that I can
[Music]
Wow